good evening everyone I'm Andrew Warner
I'm one of The Producers here at the
long now Foundation thanks for coming
out
tonight um a few housekeeping items
before we get started um if you have a
cell phone please remember to turn it
off or make it so it doesn't make
noise uh Denise's book is for sale in
back um it's awesome I thoroughly enjoy
it I bet you will
too uh tonight's talk is about an hour
long and afterwards we'll be hanging out
afterwards and the conversation
continues highly recommend you
stay I'm really excited about our talk
tonight uh looking at history the two
biggest dangers the civilizational
continuity seem to be climate crisis and
bad fiscal policy that creates economic
inequality we spent a good amount of
time thinking about climate crisis but
less on the economic narratives and
paradigms that structure our society
these economic narratives have shaped
what who and how we value different
parts of our world too often we've taken
these narratives for granted as
immutable facts about the world yet it's
becoming increasingly apparent that to
have a successful long-term civilization
some of these economic narratives need
to be seriously
rethought our speaker tonight Denise
Hearn has spent the last decade
examining these narratives understanding
how these narratives became policy and
figuring out how we can find new
narratives that actually serve humans
after her talk Denise will be joined on
stage for the Q&A by Vicky
[Music]
Saunders Vicki is an entrepreneur and
Mentor who specializes in organizing
communities to build and nurture
Innovative values aligned businesses
that actually work to make the world a
better place and now please welcome our
speaker for tonight Denise
[Applause]
[Music]
Hearn I've paid them to be here
um thank you so much this is truly a
dream come true and uh a complete honor
to be here this evening thank you all
for showing up and sorry there are not
enough seats for all of you um I uh I'm
gonna Just Launch straight in um my talk
is in five parts and it starts with the
story so part one a 4,000 year old
story rounding a corner on the winding
forested road dance partner to the
Island's perimeter we came across a
small public park as the sun began to
set and the air infused with the
crispness of Falls yielding cycle we
felt beckoned welcome to divert our
already mandering Journey we followed
winding paths into the Lush Pacific
Northwest forest on a Hilltop
overlooking Puget Sound Maple Leaves
larger than our heads formed a natural
boardwalk and the waves gently swooshed
the ancient rhythm them of water
touching
land after some time exploring we found
a path that traced a small hill up and
then
down widening into a most sacred site a
perfectly constructed
Labyrinth a swirling collection of
stones draped in sunset's rightest color
I set foot on slick Stone the colors
further deepened by an afternoon rain
each Stone pulled from surrounding
beaches had been selected and placed
with the utmost care color variations
yellow black red and white formed bands
streaking through the winding path time
seemed to stand still elongate and
travel in Reverse it bent like
origami time became tall as I walked at
top centuries of tradition and ancient
wisdom I only later learned that the
late Mosaic artist Jeffrey Bale had
modeled the Labyrinth after a 13th
century French Cathedral while also
including 12 rings to signify the
seasonal and lunar cycles the artist
also Incorporated four colors to invoke
the Native American medicine wheel the
Labyrinth was an homage to the rituals
and spiritual paths across many
centuries and traditions meditative
walking a human inheritance from all
over the
globe this experience connected me to a
truth beyond my own body beyond my own
lifespan beyond my sense of a contained
self I found it difficult to sum up in
words language is necessarily derivative
our of our embodied interaction with the
world before we have language we have
sensory experience we have breath we
have connectedness in the womb before we
have language we have the gift of a
mother's body her food her
energy language becomes a mediated layer
through which we try and relay our
experiences in a multi-sensory world a
conduit and then it becomes its own
experience it's meta structure of how we
process and interpret the
world now labyrinths like the one that
my husband and I found on Banbridge
Island near Seattle are an ancient
archetype that are estimated to be about
4,000 years old not quite 10,000 but I
thought you know fitting opening for
this talk and I didn't know much about
the history of labyrinths until I wase
preparing for this talk um though I've
been drawn to them throughout my life
and spiritual practice and one of the
earliest known references to labyrinths
is the myth of the minur and the
Labyrinth in Greek mythology which dates
back hundreds of years uh BC in this
myth a half man half bull the minur is
imprisoned by King MOS and banished to
wander a labyrinth uh until he is killed
by Theus who finds his way back out of
the labyrinth using a ball of thread
given to him by Princess
ariadne and this story inspired ancient
crean coins you can see the Labyrinth
there and the form of the labyrinth has
been incarnated all across the world as
as design elements in Roman Mosaic
floors Cathedral designs in the medieval
Christian
period um and in English and Italian
Gardens and today as spaces for quiet
reflection for all who who enter uh now
I saw Jenny Odell's recent long now talk
which was absolutely Transcendent um and
she had this line where she said the
most important technology that we've
ever had is the
story uh but stories only work through
the telling
this story this story of the labyrinth
has cascaded through 4,000 years of
human embodied living and practice to
find its way to me in Seattle and to
find its way to you
tonight labyrinths are a collective
human story across cultures time periods
and locations that have become
physically embodied in places worldwide
of course there are many examples of
this a story a ritual made physically
manifest
part two stories and our economic
storytelling our world is built on
stories on paradigms and ways of
understanding the world and our role in
it Neil Gman also gave a talk I think
this talk is like mostly referencing
previous long Now talks um but Neil Gman
H gave a talk here a number of years ago
entitled how stories last and he said
that trees at their utmost you know
limit can live for up to 5,000 years
which is
already mind-boggling animals uh at the
outer edge of the range can live up to
300 years and stories last much much
longer uh and so our oldest human
stories have been passed from generation
to generation and Outlast any living
creature making them in a sense
alive now to me nowhere is this more
evident than in the stories we tell
ourselves about the
economy what is the economy it's
actually quite a difficult question one
thing for for certain though is that the
economy is not a neutral thing the
language we use to describe it could
lead us to believe this it's a machine
one that we can Kickstart with enough uh
stimulus money from central banks or
nation states or that ex exists in the
S&P 500 or the global Commodities Market
we have you know different ways of
calculating the amount of money that
circulates in the economy M1 M2
measurements of money supply and so
forth but no the economy is an emergence
phenomenon largely based on adopted
stories and the values they contain and
how these values become formalized
through law regulation technology and so
forth and one of the places where the
values of an economic era manifest
themselves is actually in the skyline of
our cities so if you take London for
example where I lived for a few years um
the skyline of London used to be
dominated by religious buildings because
the church represented one of the most
powerful Economic Institutions of the
time
time later as the role of the state grew
as provisioner of uh public services and
Security Buildings like the Elizabeth
Tower Big Ben large judicial legislative
buildings emerged with all their
Grandeur and now of course the city of
London is dominated by banks financial
institutions and luxury condos uh which
is the case with many large cities today
these stories these paradigms and
Notions of who we are as a species quite
literally scaffold the world
they embody and serve as the great
monuments to our economic paradigms and
cultural metam memes of different
eras these stories become physically uh
embodied in the in the substrate of our
world they become
institutionalized through Technologies
administrative processes bureaucracy
case law Regulatory and policy documents
and approaches and this aies um through
feedback loops inherent to our
system power centers are institutions
like the church the State financial
markets can Orient the entire legal and
financial apparatus around their
entrenchment they impose their values
through encoding the law around their
protection so there's a a fantastic book
um called the code of
capital some fans in the audience uh by
cathina pistor and um she points out
that what we call Capital is really
coded from few legal modules uh that
have laun existed so contract law
property law collateral law trust law
corporate and bankruptcy law and
interestingly I didn't know this but she
said the two predominant legal systems
English common law and New York state
law dominate Global Capital formation
and laws and that London and New York
house all of the top 100 law firms
globally as well as many of the largest
global financial
institutions she says this is where most
capital is coded today especially
Financial Capital the intangible Capital
that exists only in law the historical
precedent for Global rule by one or
several Powers is Empire Law's Empire
has less need for troops it relies
instead on the normative authority of
the law and its most powerful battlecry
is but it is
legal so what is normative Authority uh
in law some version essentially of
Collective Agreement about what is
morally or socially acceptable so we
first create social and moral judgments
about how to ascribe value in the
economy and then we codify it in law and
we allocate the law around the
protection of those
judgments so stock market value is
actually a measure so the S&P 500 is
just a measure of expectations of future
performance and what are expectations
they are collective agreements
containing Baseline assumptions about
the future and its projections they are
stories I love this quote um I basically
like I just weave my talk around quotes
that I like um but I love this quote by
a Harvard Economist um stepen marglin
who says that economics formalizes the
cultural presuppositions of modernity
into a coherent framework the
assumptions of Economics are the myths
of
modernity so a question I will leave you
with to end part two what values do we
want to manifest themselves in the
skylines of our great cities in the
future
Future Part three the myth of
objectivity and neutrality how's
everyone doing good excellent great
thank you um so when we observe the
physical and sociocultural changes that
result from economic regime changes as
we saw with London we can see that these
paradigms and shifts are not neutral
they create winners and losers they
shape our Collective lived reality which
in turn shapes us in a reflexive Loop
however one of the um most persistent
myths and stickiest modern stories of
the economics discipline uh which has
Gravely affected our policymaking is a
myth of
neutrality that economics is a mostly
objective mathematical discipline
economics has for the last 200 years or
so started with this Paradigm uh bounded
autonomous rational man disconnected
from natural systems complex systems of
interconnection and maximalist to his
own own
desires economics started with this one
Locus or unit of creation and built an
entire discipline from that Locus and of
course it was from the perspective of
Highly Educated and Wealthy males um
which were obviously not representative
of the whole of human experience um but
this Foundation became the backdrop
against which most modern economics
rests its intellectual axioms despite
wanting to present as a purely
mathematical discipline every individual
is seen as a rational atomized actor in
complete control of their choices within
a neutral Market there's very little if
any recognition in traditional economic
theory about how cultural narratives of
bodily hierarchies racism sexism ableism
agism affect Market participation all
bodies are treated the same in economics
we come with no history we come to the
market with no
Heritage this was a very effective way
of masking power
dynamics social theorists poets
activists other wisdom Keepers across
time have investigated power of course
because it's Central to our Human
Experience so Maki Hobbs Aristotle James
Baldwin Hannah arent Angela Davis audre
Lord B hooks um I mean name you know the
list goes on and on and yet traditional
economics is largely silent on power it
has little to no epistemological
framework for understanding how power
influences markets and our experience of
them despite power differences between
persons being one of the most Salient
embodied experiences of human
life economists however tended to view
these problems outside of their domain
despite the enormous influence of our
bodies on our economic participation
economics was seen as computational
scientifically rigorous and objective
the blow um chart here by British
theoretical physicist and mathematician
John D Barrow shows a number of
scientific Fields um and he's mapped
them accordingly to the complexity of
the phenomenon on the ex axis and then
the uncertainty about the basic
equations on the y- axis so you can see
uh turbulence as an example um is highly
complex but we know how to model it
mathematically whereas climate Dynamics
are more uncertain can anyone see where
economics
say U hi it's up there in the corner
highly uncertain uh about basic equ
equations and highly
complex so while other scientific
disciplines like complexity science and
dynamical system science and so forth
disproved some of the foundational
tenants and assumptions of neoclassical
economics like General equilibrium
Supply demand curves that neatly meet in
you know with an ex um or individual
self-interest aggregating into the
highest social good that's a fallacy of
composition it doesn't hold true in
emergent systems um those with hegemonic
power imp positions of influence in
policymaking the Judiciary and so on
continue to maintain these basic
assumptions
even though it's scientifically and
visibly inaccurate so for example in the
domain where I work most of the time
which is antitrust and competition
policy economists have radically altered
the way that the law is understood and
enforced now antitrust in the US was
originally focused squarely on the
market power of dominant firms and using
public power to resist de facto private
regulatory regimes which undermine
democracy however these concerns and
questions about the role of the
corporation and societ soety were
intentionally deemphasized in the 1970s
and 80s with a a very intentional
strategy of intellectual capture and new
normative interpretations of the law
which emphasized something called the
consumer welfare standard um which
essentially privileged efficiency over
other social goods so neoliberals
attempted to make competition more
neutral and scientific by elevating the
role of economists in adjudicating the
law so when a when you know a case was
brought econom would be brought in and
they would use uh and this still happens
today that complex equations related to
calculating market share and
anti-competitive harms and benefits um
they were all invented predominantly to
serve the interest of merging parties
firms claimed that efficiencies that
would be gained through amassing Market
power so through mergers and
Acquisitions would be passed on to
consumers in the form of lower prices so
efficiency was seen as the highest
social good and this was a value
judgment masquerading as mathematical
rigor
of course efficiency and low prices are
generally good things you know we like
those and they're of of course real
trade-offs to wrestle with regarding
markets that benefit from economies of
scale and network effects and so on but
the undemocratic decision to make these
things the normative goal of a really
important area of policy and law ra
radically restructured the
economy competition policy's narrow
focus on consumer welfare over the last
45 years saw
the tech Giants Ascend to new heights
with little to no scrutiny or challenges
to mergers um a focus on lowering prices
for consumers meant that new atiz
strategies like monetizing users's
attention while offering free products
went ungoverned by competition
Regulators so the Federal Trade
Commission did a report um in in 2021
and they showed that from 2010 to 2019
alphabet Amazon Apple Microsoft and
Facebook acquired 600 116 companies and
a spree of Acquisitions and not a single
one was blocked by The
Regulators uh yeah so not only the price
effects uh of that but non-price effects
from concentrated markets like threats
to democracy or privacy the effects on
workers rights or the environment were
mostly ignored mergers largely went
unchallenged leading to Market
concentration across many sectors of the
economy which is now well documented in
the US Canada Europe and increasingly so
in other jurisdictions um so I wanted to
show you a couple of of charts here so
this is an Old Chart but I think it
visualizes really well this is banking
consolidation um until 2009 so you can
see how all of the number of banks that
we had that sort of through the merger
and acquisition process end up with only
four major um players and this you could
replicate across every industry
imaginable um this is from my old um a
DC policy group that I used to work for
called the American economic Liberties
project uh they have a whole report of
these images that are just striking this
one shows elsur Exotica which is a
sunglasses brand and they are the global
eyewear monopolist they own all of the
brands that are listed here and they
also um they not only own the lenses but
they own the um the glasses the lenses
and then they vertically integrated and
they own things like sunglasses Huts so
when you go into a Sunglasses Hut you oh
look at all these brands that are
competing uh but actually they own them
all and then I recently stayed at a
hotel in Montreal and um and it's like
one of these things that now you know
once you have a market power lens and
you see consolidation you can't um
you're like the worst person to bring to
parties because you just can't stop
talking about it but um I stayed at one
of their hotels and they were bragging
on the screen about all of the brands in
their portfolio so this is this is all
of the um various Hotel brands that
bonvoy Marriott owns now which I didn't
realize Ritz Carlton W hotels etc
etc um
so okay wait I'm Gonna Save that can I
go back yes sorry okay so perhaps um
most ironically the promise of lower
prices from efficiency gains also
largely failed to materialize so one
study in the US by economist John quaka
showed that when mergers led to or fewer
significant competitors in one industry
Prices rose 95% of the time um and why
because this is the strategy because
firms gain Market power they gain
pricing power and they can utilize that
either in the way of doing um higher
prices for consumers higher markups
which are um you know very very high
today or they can also exercise that
pricing power against uh suppliers or
workers in the way of um lower
wages so we see this is now continuing
with you know private Equity doing
serial serial Acquisitions or rollups
where they purchase a number of small
independent businesses and combine them
for so-called efficiency gains but often
it's for pricing power and um they're
doing this and everything from Dental
practices to mobile home parks to
Fitness Gyms to psychedelic mushroom
treatment centers um so yeah it's uh
it's a it's a it's a well-worn
story so the I guess I'll show you chart
now so this is an interesting chart that
shows over time um it plots the
antitrust cases against merger m&a
volume and so you can see that when you
have high antitrust enforcement that
essentially existed in sort of like the
1940s to 1960s um then you have you know
a significant decrease in the volume of
m&a and then since 1980 the enforcement
has completely dropped off and you've
had merger wave after merger wave after
merger
wave so this story about efficiency
gains neutral economies and so forth has
radically reshaped economic allocation
and it's led to higher inequality among
a number of other well recognized social
and economic problems um like low
workers wages low growth and Innovation
fewer startups and so on so Market
fundamentalism marked by kind of a Laz
Fair attitude towards public
intervention in markets I think created
many of the problems we experience today
and I love this quote from a 1970s essay
called this the tyranny of structural
lessness by feminist author Joe Freeman
so she says to strive for a
structureless group is as useful and as
deceptive as to aim at an objective news
story a value-free social science or a
free economy a la Fair group is about as
realistic as a la Fair Society the idea
becomes a smoke screen for the strong or
the lucky to establish unquestioned
hemony over
others it goes
on this hemony can be so easily
established Lish because the idea of
structurelessness does not prevent the
formation of informal structures only
formal ones similarly La Fair philosophy
did not prevent the economically
powerful from establishing control over
wages prices and the distribution of
goods it only prevented the government
from doing so thus structurelessness
becomes a way of masking
power so liberalizing markets and
granting them Freedom was a
philosophical and practical abdication
of responsibility for the fundamental
moral ethical and political questions
about how we should organize terms of
trade uh and public life now of course
there are many economists who have been
pointing out these fundamental flaws in
economic reasoning for decades many of
them female and particularly women of
color economists and academics and of
course activists and public policy
Advocates but their work has been
sidelined or deprioritized in literature
and in policymaking largely because it
threatened established power structures
so my point of of all of this is to
essentially say that all economics is
political economics of one kind or
another because it must start with a
notion of human behavior which is
inextricably conjoined with moral and
social dynamics and
questions how are we doing on
time okay okay
excellent part
four oh I was going to tell you about my
reply on Twitter but we'll skip that for
now um okay so part four profit
paradigms there's an increasing
disconnect between the logic of
financial markets and planetary
realities as we Face Down huge
Collective challenges like climate
change inequality biodiversity loss
water usage and so forth metac crisis
poly crisis whatever you'd like to call
it um many attempts have been made to
deploy private Finance to Aid in the the
amelioration of these challenges and of
course estim are in the trillions alone
for climate change
mitigation um and we need private
Finance absolutely but as a result a
proliferation of some formulation of
this statement U has occurred people
plus Planet plus profit equals impact
and I saw this on someone's LinkedIn and
you know impact investing ESG
stakeholder capitalism sustainable
Finance Etc I've worked Within These
communities I've researched many of
these movements but when I saw this put
so sort of simplistically I couldn't get
a question out of my head which is what
is
profit profit seems like such an
intuitive and self-evident concept that
we rarely pause to reflect on it kind of
a primordial received wisdom uh total
revenue minus total expenses is
profit of course most accounting is not
this simple or straightforward and even
if it were how is profit derived who or
what bears the cost of production of
those profits I.E the externalities and
what then is profits ultimate
relationship negative and positive to
impact I found this excellent paper uh
by a professor at you the University of
Chicago named Jonathan Levy um it's
called accounting for profit and the
history of capital Levy traces our
evolving conceptions of profit over time
and as he does this we come to
understand that profit is not a constant
or self-evident concept at all in fact
our current way of accounting for profit
is very young in the expans of human
commercial time it's a new story
so profit as we conceptualize it today
did not exist before the mid 19th
century um ancient Society Accounting in
ancient societies was likely to take the
form of credit and debit ledgers as
David Graber uh talks about in his book
Debt the first 5,000 years he says for
most of human history at least the
history of states and Empires most human
beings have been told that they're
debtors so indebtedness to someone else
and their indebtedness to you was the
primary method of account for most
exchanges wealth usually of Kings
Emperors and Nobles was measured in
long- range assets like land or
political or militaristic power here's a
um a woodblock print of the Dutch East
India Company ship so when the first
Global Mega corporations were formed
they were given their license to operate
by Royal Charter and sought to expand
the longrange assets of their respective
Empires they did this by amassing
stealing more land tradable Goods uh
political and mil militaristic power and
uh the goal essentially was not profit
as we conceptualize it but it was
colonization it was Empire expansion and
wealth
extraction if you fast forward to the
pre-industrial age in the US sort of
before
1850 this was the age of you know local
independent businesses family-owned
businesses before the mid 1800s many
firms did not track or report profits
and we know this because in uh the 1830s
the used federal government surveyed
manufacturing firms to determine their
rate of profit it was called the mlan
report and it showed that half of the
survey respondents did not report a rate
of profit because they didn't measure it
they were essentially happy if uh they
just ended the year with a surplus and
you know that was fine then when you get
into the industrial era profit mostly
came from lowering costs like labor um
and it it tended to be reinvested in
additional manufacturing plants and
Factory railroad expansion steam engines
and the robber barons built great
industrial Empires this way controlling
the fundamental infrastructure of
Commerce and as they grew in political
power arguments about the corporation's
role in society crescendoed and that's
when the first Anti-Trust laws were
passed the Sherman Act in 1890 and The
Clayton Act in
1914 and then in the mid 20th century we
see the rise of the multinational
corporation and profit at this point um
mostly becomes an internal corporate
accounting metric to help them make
sense of this very diverse dispersed
corporate activities all over the globe
uh this is also the period where Milton
Friedman puts his ideas to paper and
legitimizes the notion that greed or
profit maximization is is uh akin to
societal good and today's profit regime
I call it's better to sell Bitcoin than
Teslas um so our current profit regime
starting about from the 1980s to today
has been irreversibly changed by the
financialization of companies so firms
now use use complex financing
instruments including derivatives to
adjust the assets and liabilities on
their balance sheet corporate
accountants adopted something called
Mark to Market um or fair value
accounting methods which uh basically
values the assets at what they could be
sold on the market for
today and then this gets reflected in
the company's stock price so today
companies can earn profits essentially
simply by rearranging the financial
assets on their balance sheet instead of
by providing high quality goods and
services so for my my favorite example
which is how I named this profit regime
um is in 2021 Tesla had a really great
quarter but it didn't actually earn
these profits by selling cars it uh its
soaring profits were mostly from selling
Bitcoin and carbon credits to other
automakers to help meet their emissions
mandates and that was that was how they
actually stayed in the in the green
today around 90% of S&P 500 uh market
value is intangible value as
financialization has increased the
intangible value of things like Goodwill
intellectual property patents or
trademark Rights created uh by
Collective imagination and coded into
law now dominate what we think of as
economic health and vibrancy now profits
of course can come from innovating and
providing better products and services
but they often uh too often can come
from erecting Market modes either by
acting as a gatekeeper across a critical
line of Commerce and charging High tolls
like apple taking 27% from App
Developers
um or we we recently learned in the
Department of Justice case against
Google that Google was paying Apple 26.3
billion dollar a year I think to be the
default browser on Apple devices so
essentially to maintain its um its
Monopoly in search that was 6.7 of
Apple's Global
Revenue that is how Apple earned a
significant amount of its profits was
getting Google to pay it to Main pance
Monopoly so these and other Dynamics
created a corporation that decoupled
profit from productive investment
companies are not interested in growing
their businesses traditionally uh but
are incentivized to find and exploit new
collections of assets with which to
pursue Financial engineering and
valuation expansions so all of this is
to say that profit is not a
straightforward concept uh and how we
account for profit has major implication
on the shapes of
markets um I think this is my last qu
quote thank you stay with me oh yeah
there's there's our guy
um profit paradigms have the power to
alter the structural conditions of
capitalism I hope to demonstrate as they
themselves emerge from the structural
possibilities at stake in any given
moment of capitalism's History given the
particular concrete forms of capital as
well as the cognitive orientations that
make profiting from them possible today
the future of profit the future history
of capital is very much up for
grabs last part part five
stratigraphy many well-meaning attempts
to restructure capitalism have yet to
make tremendous progress on are many
many issues there's no shortage of New
Economic thinking new legal thinking so
why is the system so
resistant one explanation is that the
system is resistant to change because
the legal and Regulatory system is easy
to game because the state largely
protects Capital through its legal
enforcement mechanisms also that most in
Innovations eventually have to graft on
to the existing legal and financial
infrastructure if they want to scale to
any
degree however I would argue that in
addition the system is resilient to
change because it is an emerging system
that has been co-created out of our own
fractured thought
patterns so in physicist David bomb's
thought as a system he contends that
there is a systemic fault in the whole
of thought and that the pervasive
tendency of thought to struggle against
its own Creations is the central dilemma
of our
time the more I have dug into how
decisions and debates are shaped The
more I've realized it's about
terminology and language which emanate
from and co-shape our
thought and that's where you see things
like
efficiency a
word that has a meaning we've imbued it
with come to radically restructure how
the economy operates um in uh in her
book in Robin wal kimmer's book rating
sweet grass she talks about the language
of the pami tribe in the Great Lakes
region and how they have 70% verbs as
opposed to English which has only 30%
verbs and the Le the rest is
nouns this difference even in language
and how we've structured language
canotes um a kind of
objectification a a con verion of
aliveness and movement into static fixed
points new stories and new language will
be needed or perhaps old stories new to
many of us stuck in Western ideological
hemony but luckily the system is Stories
the system is a series of moral
judgments the system is those values
ossified through procedure code
regulations these stories are changeable
and they are these stories are
rewritable and are re being Rewritten
constantly even today we see things that
we didn't imagine were possible in the
US um a major Revival of industrial
policy economic textbooks are actually
being Rewritten there's a comeback of uh
Public Utilities law Canada just last
month where I'm from uh dropped in in
our competition policy it had What's
called the efficiencies defense so
written into the written into the
legislation that said as long as firms
promised these great efficiency gains
they could merge uh what would otherwise
be deemed illegal mergers they took that
out amazing um small winds you got to
celebrate um so you know all these
things are are changing but um they need
to be politically instantiated and I
think the tide is slow slowly turning
part of the challenge though for 21st
century finance and economic
policymaking will actually be how much
can we hold economic reasoning
back in other words to prescribe areas
that the market should and will not
touch things we refuse to atise to
monetize to commodify to ascribe
economic value to because attempts to
apply Market reasoning to everything
from carbon markets to the newly created
national uh sorry natural asset
companies will not on their own solve
our climate crisis because our profit
paradigms bind them in ways that
undermine their objectives and fall prey
to the same power dynamics and
fragmentation of thought that bom and
kimra and others are pointing us to
these um and our our economic puzzles
can feel like mazes from which there's
no way out this was Bloomberg's uh most
recent
cover and I thought it was fitting
because I thought well maybe the
Labyrinth can offer us some
lessons the Labyrinth teaches us that
this is both an individual and
Collective Journey or quest which
requires letting go of our certainties
and our desire for linear
Pathways it teaches us that the only way
out is
through my friend Olive told me
that it also teaches us that the same
form can take on new meanings talismans
like the Labyrinth evolve over time
they're built upon layers and layers of
sedimentary thought and Collective
narrative perhaps our some of our
talismans of economic storytelling like
profit or value will evolve different
meanings throughout time to be more
expansive more liberatory more Equitable
for all living beings
the Labyrinth teaches us that life is a
continual flow that we participate in
and that at any point in that flow is
neither good nor bad it is simply part
of the uncoiling journey leading us back
to ourselves and to our shared sense of
belonging
here many waves of humans and our
Collective storytelling have structured
this world that we call reality our
buildings our inventions and our highest
art add to the layered stratigraphy of
time Rising standing and falling in a
cyclical pattern of human story when all
of this all buildings structures
physical embodiments of our cultural
values are reduced to a layer of
stratigraphy in the geological record
what do we want it to say about
us may the long now Inspire our moral
imagination to co-create a new story
together thank
[Applause]
you
thank
you I also just wanted to quickly
acknowledge um a few others who have
really shaped my thought that I didn't
mention in the talk so my Katrine kilios
Marcel Michelle Omar
meam Olive everyone meet them afterwards
please um Vicky Saunders Lisa saaks
Audrey Lord Dila Meadows and too many
others to mention thank you
[Applause]
hello on there we go we're on hey
everyone wasn't that amazing
clap can we scoot over yeah this table's
blocking me yeah sure more connected
more there's so many threads it's kind
of hard to take but I I would love to
leave time for people to ask questions
um and I think I I'd like to start with
embodiment uh and you started with
embodied economics I've learned a lot
about this from you you know there's
often this quote that the longest path
you take is from your head to your heart
um and as we start to embody more of the
values that we want like what why
embodiment why does that matter to you
and why embodied economics can you say a
bit more about that yeah I mean I think
I think we're drawn to things that we
need to integrate ourselves so it's you
know there's some of it that's sort of a
a
introspective um Journey for me about
what is it what it what does it mean to
feel embodied you know in my own body um
and I think I also have reflected on the
fact that you know I grew up in a
religious household uh in the Christian
tradition and I was quite devout I
thought about becoming um going to going
to Seminary at one point and then I went
to Business School um but uh you know
but I there's this sort of mystical
claim as part of the Christian story
that still resonates with me where
there's this incredible sort of
paradoxical notion that the Divine and
and and the human can coexist in one
place and there could be 100% Divine
100% human and that actually um God
embodies herself um in the in the human
body and and I think that there's a
notion there about multiple truths
existing at the same time Rebecca and I
were speaking before this um one of my
favorite found words is antimony which
means two seemingly oppositional truths
that coexist and I think there's
something to that around embodiment
being being a way to reduce
fragmentation that normally comes with
sort of cognitive
processing of the world that it's a way
to holistically understand our place
here um and so I think it's a journey
I'm on to understand what that means and
not also you know not just myself but as
a uh you know tikn Han has that
wonderful phrase interbeing this this
sense that um we are so connected to
ourselves and to the more than human
world in ways that we can't even
understand or fathom um and so there's
something there too about this embodied
sense
being um not just a physical reality but
it's a continuation of sort of energy
and life flow across
time I was uh recently at this event and
and um struggling around some how to get
things done more quickly Etc and this
indigenous Elder said to me Vicki a
short-term project is 40
years a long-term project is
400 um and I think here we're talking in
10,000 years so much longer but there's
this line on the long now website about
being a good
ancestor and I was thinking about you
you were talking about the layers of
sediment and US kind of composting ideas
over time so we can get to what's coming
next and I wonder if you see signs of
Hope um or Pathways opening around this
shift of reality because it seems like
we're quite stuck in this is the way to
do things and until someone can show a
way that could replicate this that you
can think of but then you go to David
bom and you go like that's not going to
be possible like what's coming next is
going to be some emergent something I
wonder if you and you mentioned
emergence here are is that maybe a
pathway for us what do you think is
coming through yeah I mean I I think I
see all kinds of threads I mean a lot of
folks in this room are weaving them um
and I think sometimes it can it can
definitely
feel I can feel overwhelming the more
you sort of go down the rabbit hole on
um all of the ways that the
structure has that kind of inertia you
know this how the systems inertia really
manifests in very practical ways um
but I
do I don't know I mean I don't know
what's coming next I think
um what I I was just reading the other
day will and Ariel Durant uh were
historians and they said that you know
one of so much of this is cyclical like
we think it's new but it's really not
and um one of the things that they
identified was that especially with
wealth inequality that wealth tends to
accumulate um you know slowly over time
but then once it reaches a point where
there's a huge Divergence that there's
sort of two Pathways forward one is some
sort of violent Uprising where wealth
gets distributed through War um or uh or
you can cancel the debt ledgers you can
actually have a really interventionist
program by the state to redistribute the
the ledgers and um so one there's like
blueprints you know for what for how to
do this that I think we take some
rediscovery um but I also think
that yeah that sense of emergence we I
think the the the hard thing is it's
like so hard for us to imagine um what
is possible
but there's this reflexive process right
where we put IDE ideas out into the
world that sort of emanate and um
there's the the um what do you call it
um sorry the upward causation and then
you know in emerging systems there's
also like a that reflexive process of
the downward causation but if you think
about a starling
murmuration um even if one Starling just
goes a little bit
off the whole flock will kind of come
and Orient itself around that and that
those outlying those one that one
outlier actually can have a systemic
effect um and so I do think that that's
possible and I don't know where where
all of those different intervention
points will be but I that's where I sort
of maintain hope is knowing that it is
possible great thank you uh do people
does anyone have a question they're
passing around microphones there we go
hi there
hi thank you for the talk that was
beautiful um I'm I'm thinking about the
idea
of um this concept of uh necessary and
sufficient conditions for um something
to be true and I love the emphasis on
the power of
narrative and as you've talked about the
narratives that have been powerful to
you it sort of brings up the question
for me of whether or not we think and
you think that the narrative is uh a
necessary but not sufficient condition
or whether narrative is perhaps like if
powerful enough narrative is sufficient
you know if we just tell powerful enough
stories uh is that something that we
could kind of Bank on and just go
forward but
that's yeah that's a really interest
interesting question thank you I I guess
my reaction
is the more that I have started to view
reality through this lens of everything
being stories it's sort of like I find
it hard to undo um and so I think that
it's I
think I guess what sort of bom was
trying to get with her how I interpret
it is that it's not just about sort of
like imposing a new story it's you know
we it's this Con it's this constant sort
of like millu everything here a story um
and we participate that in that every
day and so I think there's there's a way
to do it in which maybe it becomes more
more embodied more Collective um it's
not about a sort of imposition yeah of
this new narrative and but I would also
say that I guess as I was trying to sort
of allude to or talk about that those
you know our narratives do become very
aifi through all of these various
processes um um and and that does take
time to unwind so it's not just that you
need a new story but you do need to then
have all the sort of like supporting
apparatus that comes alongside to
condition that I don't know if that
answers your question but that would be
I don't know my initial thought I just
like to add something to that because
there's a a book that's not yet here in
the US but it's in Australia written by
Tyson yapor who's an Aboriginal uh
scholar and it's called right story
wrong story and he says it's very easy
to spin up wrong stories very quickly
and they go viral especially these days
but right stories are Community produced
and people have a shared truth that they
live through it and it takes about a
decade to create H and I found that
really interesting so that's another
person out there with that model yes
wait okay thank you hi there so I very
much appreciate the talk obviously
you're speedrunning like a very deep
intellectual work I'd love to zoom in
though to um the notion about
objectivity and I I'd love like a market
when I think about a market and what a
market Market is attempting to do it's
sort of like a metaphysics it's not
trying to I'm I'm sorry a meta ethics
it's not trying to tell you what to
believe it's trying to adjudicate a way
of agreeing of coming to what we should
do based on a set of disagreeing moral
principles across a society and so when
you talk about unweaving objectivity I
feel like there's like a double-edged
sword there on one hand you you fall
into brute disagreement and on the other
hand you do unweave kind of greenwashing
where the market is trying to smuggle in
certain principles as if they are just
objective so wonder if you can talk
about like how much should you unweave
the story in in in order to try to
unweave the fairness versus try to say
this is the meta ethical framework in
which we're
operating yeah I mean I I think I would
have a slightly different framing that I
think that markets
are I think that markets are public
Creations governed by essentially either
democratically determined rules or
social norms and so I think it's
impossible to sort of extract them from
the social Dynamic and the some sense of
shared coherence about what that is and
over time of course we've made decisions
like okay we we're not going to trade
certain things in markets humans body
parts Etc right so um so there's always
some set of shared assumptions or Norms
I think that construct the market and
also you know like Graber points out
that actually most markets um didn't
sort of naturally emerg from The Butcher
and the baker wanting to exchange for
the thing you know was like the state
actually created markets mostly to
provision armies and so there's always a
complex inner dynamic between
um between like the polity creating a
set of shared Norms around how to do
exchanges so I don't know if
um I'm now I'm like totally forgetting
your question I'm sorry but um but I
think so I guess what I'm saying is I'm
starting at a different point where I
don't think that markets are sort of
esoteric things that exist on their own
like they they
naturally occur within those within
those structures and therefore if we
assume that they don't then we're
masking the fact that we are making so
social or moral judgments in their in
how they operate and function um and you
know just to like maybe bring this down
to earth a little bit one of the
initiatives that I helped um launch was
something called access to markets and
it was it was really focused on trying
to help entrepreneurs you know mostly we
think of entrepreneurs struggling
because they need to raise Capital which
of course is is a thing access to
Capital but we are saying like once you
raise money and you try to actually do
this thing you're going to encounter all
kinds of Gatekeepers and all kinds of um
blocks within what we think of as
obviously sort of like free markets um
which are going to make it difficult for
you and um I mean not that we said that
they said that they told us that
so again it's sort of and those
blockages that they encounter whether
you're an app developer having to deal
with Apple's 30% cut or whatever like
those are all things that we
construct those Norms are things that
we're going to co-create and construct
together and figure out how to how to do
that so um I don't know if
that okay thanks I appreciate the
question though up here at the
front uh great talk very
thought-provoking thank you in um
Frederick War's book the culture of
markets which is very align of if you're
familiar with it he talks about the way
that kind of CEOs create cultures within
their companies and the way that um
marketers create uh culture as well and
so I was curious about the way you
started the talk talking about the
influence of stories and stories
potentially being the oldest living
thing in ways if you could share some of
your thoughts around who are the
storytellers in creating kind of
thisy
I mean I think I think a lot of it is
inherited in the sense that
we it's not easy to identify a
particular person or um how it's sort of
that emergent process of how you know
how it has come to shape the reality
that we live in but I
think I think that's what I'm interested
in is sort of like who are the new
storytellers and and I think they
will most likely be
unexpected um to me anyways
and I don't know yeah do you have a
thought on that question sorry I'm just
sitting with it is this such a beautiful
question I don't have a good response to
it I just no I don't I don't have a
names I think there are threads of
collectives people are talking about
regenerative economies and starting to
think things through their practitioners
out there doing interesting things a lot
is just really under the radar um and
like I don't think the future is going
to be this like one uh replacement for
what we already have like we're waiting
for this one thing is going to replace
it there's going to be this I I really
feel like it's going to be this
distributed networked
multi-local um emerging thing that won't
be clear until it's here like it's all
done right but it's it's all of a sudden
and then it pops through I don't know
but that's
I thinking do you want
sure
um it's actually a whole bunch of
questions but um and it it has a
confession in it um so I I work for a
big public company and and I do business
with a lot of vendors and um I found
over time and it relates to your
storytelling
that especially small and upcoming
Regional vendors um as a matter of the
business business but one of the things
I really ask is where is your financing
how are you based and when I find that
there's Investment Banking and private
Equity I I I tend to avoid it because
they make these really toxic decisions
and the people that you're talking to
aren't going to be there and and and and
they've got a twoyear a fiveyear
mentality and they're going to get out
and and it's gonna it's going to turn
and and so part of as you're
storytelling the story I hear here that
I that I I think I believe is is is the
story is transferring wealth from the
uninformed to the unformed um Time and
Time time again and and we've
institutional I think it started I don't
know if started Reagan or Clinton but
where it really became
institutionalized of investment banking
and the growth so having said all of
that my question is is how do you like
is there a
regulatory like how do you change that
trajectory of
uberization because you know with
private Equity as an example Pension
funds were sold this narrative that they
would generate higher returns than
public markets and um and so so Pension
funds ended up allocating a significant
significantly more of their sort of
allocative capacity to private Equity as
a um as a capital allocation strategy
which then sort of you know Works its
way through the capital market system um
and then these private Equity firms have
to go and find all these businesses and
you know I asked my local dentist in
Seattle as an example I was like are you
still independent please say yes um and
she was but she said I get Flyers two to
three times a week asking me to sell and
she said what I think is really
Insidious is it's probably a dental cons
consolidator that's private Equity owned
but they make it look like it's another
independent dentist that wants to
acquire me um so it kind of you know
this stuff Cascades and it is really
difficult to figure out the the new like
what is a new capital markets incentive
structure that actually reverses this
and I think that's where you know I've
gone down this crazy rabbit hole on like
profit and you know so forth I do think
things are changing because
institutional investors are starting to
recognize that um perhaps like
historical Ben marks of how they've of
growth benchmarks or return benchmarks
are
significantly wrong um haven't
internalized the externalities and so
forth so like you do actually hear big
investment companies talking about this
and sort of being like how do we
reconcile these differences and um but I
do worry that then you have these other
Frameworks like um you know intangible
asset Frameworks or national natural
capital and so forth where you just
asseti more things and then you can
create more value bubbles that you put
on your balance sheet you know and so um
so I don't know how to change that I
think regulatorily speaking obviously I
mostly focus on what the FDC and the doj
do on sort of competition and antitrust
stuff um and we've had a huge Revolution
they're doing great stuff uh is it
enough no of course not um
and and I do think you know Securities
Law and all of these things like it is
very technocratic but that is
where as Katherina points out where
Capital gets coded and and where assets
come into being which are just legal
fictions like they're nothing more than
legal fictions um so I think if we can
try to think about alternative ways of
um I don't know atiz something different
for a different purpose you know and
lots of people are working on that but
it's um there's nothing that feels
concurrent to the the size and scale of
the problem that I've seen so far yeah I
think one of the things though that is
really hopeful and amazing is you know
five years ago we didn't all see this
right like it feels like we've pulled
back the curtains since Co and people
can actually see like what is coming as
a result of our systems is because of
the design of the systems and you can
talk to private Equity folks who'd be
like we'll change our Behavior if you
change the incentives right the the
problem with the behavior change the
incentive system so if we change that
like instantaneously beh would change
and so there has to be enough people
having the same shared reality that
recognize that reality is not working to
be able to empty that story and create a
new one really like that's and it feels
like that's imminent feels like there's
a lot more I mean I used to go to New
York and say everything's broken and
people be like really what's broken H
that was five years ago and now people
are like oh yeah yeah so is there one
more yes last question um yeah uh
uh thank you Denise this is an amazing
talk I'm sort of new to your work and
you've made a lot of things make make
sense to me so I really appreciate it um
it's sort of a like a circular kind of
question that has a couple of parts to
it um so it's about the indigenous
connection with um like the modern
economy and so in the spirit of that
sort of like as you're and I'm seeing
that threaded and I love that you're
sort of you know bringing the two
together um I'm curious when you sort of
look at from an indigenous perspective
and you were to sort of Define what you
know about ways of relating with life
from that way as an economic system how
you might describe that and then also
what language you might um give not to
put you on the spot or anything like
that it's totally cool but just like to
brainstorm what language you might give
to people um in the modern world that
might connect with those ways of
interconnecting and relating with life
from that econom me so to
speak yeah beautiful question I
feel I I don't
feel like I'm the one to answer it um I
think I I certainly draw inspiration
from certainly um various indigenous
communities um
but I there's a friend of mine described
also this notion of um sort of different
different layer
she described a cell and she was like
there's all the different component
parts and they all work and they have
different functions and purposes and I
think my general worldview is that
there's many types of sort of like
expertise and even language and levels
of sort of language coding that is
needed to get us to the New World um and
and so I
think I think there are many sort of
long now elements from what I understand
of a variety of different indigenous
cultures that um that we can draw
inspiration from but I wouldn't yeah I
wouldn't feel comfortable sort of naming
that language
myself do you have something down yeah I
mean this is a lot of the stuff that we
do but the do people know what the pot
latch is yeah so in indigenous culture
they used to have this they would
practice this thing called the Potlatch
where every it was their economy every
year people would accumulate the things
that they would accumulate pelts
whatever it was when they're in the
community they got distributed into the
long house and then women once a year
would redistribute the goods to the
community because just because you were
a good Hunter didn't mean it belong to
you it was for the community by the
community and when uh we came over to
this to Turtle Island we um called it
uncivilized and banned it this
redistribution of assets of the
community to everyone so that everyone
was cared for so there's lots of other
ways to do community um and lots of
examples in indigenous culture that we
have uh removed but um I one of the
things that obviously to go back and
study is thank gosh that book um that
you mentioned from Robin W hmer reading
sweet grass if you haven't read it like
really tapping into indigenous worldview
and then using your creativity to bring
that into the modern world thank you
thank you very much J in there thank you
so much thank you everyone
thank you so much um that concludes this
evening we're going to reset the room
[Music]
um